all right so I am so excited because we
are here it is Tuesday May 29th 2018 and
this is Manhattanhenge this is dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and the man who named the
event where we are Manhattanhenge okay
so so I called it to everyone's
attention okay what's this have been
going on since the grid has been up
alright but nobody's been paying
attention you know why why first it has
to be clear okay second you have to be
crossing the street okay and not
concerned about your health and
well-being while you're crossing the
street as evidenced by the number of
people who are in the middle of the
street right and you have to be on one
of the two days in which this is going
on right and I knew such a days would
exist I calculated it my first shot of
Manhattanhenge was on this very
intersection Park Avenue in 34th Street
the beautiful Empire State Building it
is right there you check it out Empire
State Building yeah baby
there you go New York New York state of
mind okay so then I published my first
photo of it okay then people started
gathering in the streets and I said look
traffic has been stopped for like coned
digging holes right before all for for
bird you know pedestrians getting hit by
car right I figured let the traffic stop
because the people want to drink in the
cosmos very nice yes yes yes and what
such event is the alignment of the
sunset on the Manhattan grid where did
you get the name Manhattan heads as a
kid I visited Stonehenge I was very
impressed it's the fact that ancient
peoples made these vertical stone
monuments and
Stonehenge itself is actually an
observatory yes and no one knew that
until like an astronomer figured that
out people said oh they're worshipping
the Sun and they're this and they're the
druids and whatever this is a freaking
observatory that can predict eclipses
okay yeah just because they're ancient
people don't mean they're stupid okay
well that is true and just because we're
modern people doesn't mean we're smart
thank you yes thank you but it's like
we're playing football back in the hood
and so now like thousands of people pour
into the street and stop traffic for a
cosmic reason absolutely yeah yeah I'm
totally into that this is your baby you
got to be proud so this happens twice a
year the same number of days before
or the June solstice as after one of our
challenges is in summertime we get as is
true for most of the country we got our
weather from the states that sit west of
us
so our weather comes from New Jersey
from New Jersey busts like storms and
things over New Jersey if the storms
over New Jersey the Sun will set behind
the storms and we get no Manhattanhenge
so I'm worried about that there's some
cloud action over there New Jersey might
be messing with us again hope another
bus coming
so you notice how anytime we dig up old
civilizations yes we say oh they worship
the Sun and this is their Sun culture so
I'm imagining the day where apocalyptic
earth and they dig up the grid of
Manhattan okay and then they try to
figure out why was it aligned this way
so if you look at what is happening in
American culture on those two days okay
the first of the Manhattan henges
happens around Memorial Day the second
one happens the second one happens near
baseball's all-star break so future so
future anthropologists would surely
judge that we aligned Manhattan in honor
of the two things America cares most
about war and baseball it's that simple
where America we love war and baseball
so what's going on is people's the
people say oh watch this what direction
does the Sun Rise and it sets in the
East so it must rise in the West so both
of them are wrong the Sun rises in the
east and sets in the west on only two
days a year okay and those are on the
equinoxes March 21st and September 21st
and why is that and every other day of
the year the Sun is rising and setting
somewhere else on the horizon okay but
why is that I did a little Trump thing
here somewhere else somewhere fantastic
so before today
what the Buffy's blood is in the way
okay so what happens is the Sun is
setting at an angle and before today
before today it has set south of this
aligned street so you would never see
the sunset right
beginning today you see the Sun cross
this field of view and today it's
setting on the grid tomorrow it's gonna
set a little farther north and a little
farther north and it'll keep doing that
until June 21st first day of summer let
me finish okay go ahead come to the
north and it's s it's farthest point
north on June 21st after that it start
to end the Sun so it slows down stops
and we're that's right suppose solstice
right Latin for a stationary Sun so
after that it starts setting backwards
again and it reappears here and this
would be around July 11th they're worse
than the bus by the way you're not
supposed to be in a bus lane officer
excuse me officer that's must be in a
bus lane okay well you know cuz I'm a
coward so do you have it Manhattan is it
looks like we're not getting it we're
not gonna get it because of the cloud
jersey took Manhattan hands from us
they put a cloud in the way curse you
New Jersey if something lives in New
Jersey I do it's my fault
you